[Music]
just gotta keep her story straight
no one's gotten away ten
[Music]
who are you I'm holding County oh you
Linden school kids on field trip this
morning found this donor have a history
of running away mrs. Larsen Rosie no j9
birth of a son
is my daughter
be here mr. Larsen look her got her head
almost cut off cut a body this one if
you're looking for connection there's
them we got the killer to put a boy
under story what is this place linen put
the gun down this house if you don't
need to be here
anything can happen on this land I think
she martini she couldn't tell anyone
about do you think we're chasing the
wrong guy
never gonna get Amari it's like if
someone crusade and know his kids are in
so much pain you said me you're trying
to say for yourself
[Music]
is a fearful thing to love what death
can touch to love the hope the dream to
be to lose be your life has lived in me
- remember this brings painful joy
because a human thing
[Music]
- love what death has touched
[Music]
hypothetically scale of one to ten how
difficult would it be for someone to
disappear family of four
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
around this place is death
[Music]
surrounded by around a bar she's our
daughter
who are these people but she's never
seen this proof
seven years ago would you witness he/she
was behind what
do you remember any of the events that
led up to your disappearance
I want you to close your eyes
I want you to imagine everything I tell
you as if you're there yourself
as if you're with me as if you are me
[Music]
I didn't disappear
I was present for all of it
[Music]
biggest mistake I made was believing
that if I cast a beautiful net I'd catch
only beautiful things
[Music]
I remember I remember everything
[Music]
now knock who's there it's the hormone
monster no no no no you gotta be kidding
me Nick is right there sir end and I'm a
good person I wouldn't do that laying
next to a friend and why am I here my
god you're always right what the hell is
wrong with me nothing you're a perfectly
normal gross little dirtbag now stare at
that cat clock and massage your dinner
no Nick's grandmother gave him that
cause she knew what she was doing yeah
she did okay
Oh what a little cluck tease her eyes
are darting back and forth thinking yeah
meow who's got the creamy I've got the
cream here oh oh my god it's okay it's
okay just picture your dad's associate
Susan Oh Susan
mmm Susan actually came to this summer
outing and she said that I was really
sprouting into a fine young man it's
right look at her sinewy arms Susan show
me your top naked yeah oh God and she's
got fallopian tubes Oh God
okay so Susan um what's it like to be in
human resources I'm done
good night you Prince of Westchester you
king of the tri-state area wait what do
we do about the mass sleep in it big
looking around a world of injustice
intolerance and huge environmental
challenges it's hard to imagine a
brighter future
but we can and we must
anyone hello
the stupid mental before system nothing
is gonna happen
[Music]
we are
sunnier future
but how long can happiness
realistically last anyhow
[Music]
have faith in the system because it
really does work private stuff is
private surviving in a week's mint come
with it define go at it
just kidding help and I think to myself
what can we do everything happens for a
reason
what I wonderful it's more like a waking
nightmare
I think to myself
[Music]
what I wonder everything happens for a
reason
[Music]
annoyed distant their clients that win
nine younger of mr. Hughes of ice rush
for meat before we had wood first book
right
they laid on me
and even status with snow line from the
islands at Idaho
the fog is the head he can feel that so
nonviolent I mean imagine what it takes
to bludgeon someone to death the lust
for control the feeling of arousal the
decision to humiliate her corpse how
could you possibly get that from an
ordinary police report
I can choke down the bile manufacture
empathy when our subjects are at least
informative we decided no one was
beneath our contentment trying to ward
you your attitude is gonna bite you in
the ass you're developing a pattern of
behavior that will not sustain you here
so young to be ruining people's lives we
need to know exactly how worried we need
this awful rage and needing to feel
emotion sorry it's not our job to
commiserate with these people it is our
job to electrocute them can't like
everything we do we're talking to Siri
okay buddy if this is gonna work we need
to talk to more subs war you want
troubles you've got to get in the dirt
with the pigs no we don't we are the FBI
[Music]
all right the next words out of your
mouth how to be the truth who are you
it's all so it's all good man I tell you
by a young guy they called him slippin
Jimmy slippin Jimmy with a law degree
I'm on the up-and-up from here on out
I'm gonna play by the rules I don't go
looking for guilty people to represent
who needs that aggravation thank you for
restoring my faith in the judicial
system you can be on one side of the law
or the other
I've known good criminals and bad cops
if you make a deal with somebody you
keep your word
he's you know in free spirit you know
I'm right if you abuse that power people
get hurt you're better than you have a
straightforward choice to make here I'm
a humble lawyer really trying to apply
my trade in an aggressive and evolving
marketplace Wow
you got a mouth on you thank you
we have $1,600,000 in cash
he split it 50/50 what stopped us I
remember you saying something about
doing the right thing I don't even know
what the condom broke but he didn't
finish it it's fine yeah but there's
little guys that come out before the big
party you know I'm gonna get the pillow
me and this young lady or yep there it
is I got it
my treat we need you to do an accent
evening like an Indian accent you know
Ben Kingsley did an accent in Gandhi and
he won the Oscar for it so like he
didn't win the Oscar just for doing the
accent I mean it wasn't an Oscar for
Best Indian accent you see the social
network the Indian guy is a white guy no
no I read that he's 1/16 Indian cares if
you go back far enough row 1/16
something I'm right 1/16 the black you
think they're to let me play played
whoever you're dating now at this stage
it could be who you end up with it's a
big decision it's all right how many
women did you meet before you decided on
line two - that's it those are on the
first lady it's a little bit too tall as
soon as he stood up I was like oh we
have to learn to make decisions man
Villages barney is like yeah it'd be an
amazing spare
don't don't yell out people's
ethnicities there are a million things
that guys have no clue about that are so
annoying
like what so you remember when we went
to brunch and we both Instagram a
picture of that frittata oh that ricotta
was fluffy as hell what are your
comments young town population biz check
my notes I want to [ __ ] your face
when you close your eyes do you see
Devon rapes on the cozy house little
Deb's running around I just see black
this is death we're seeing each other
you seem very nice I mean I was a little
worried so my friends have racist
grandmas oh I see you assumed I would
erase it just because I'm old
ah now the tables are turned sorry in
this world there are good guys and there
are bad guys and I will not be bullied
into submission you're reading the man's
part Oh God would you like to start over
yes I would I will not be bullied into
submission sorry to interrupt your wife
is on line two I'm interested in real
parts got 83 dollars in my bank accounts
and I don't know if I can pay my gas
bill I'm Sam Sylvia and this is Gro
sorry what's glow gorgeous ladies of
wrestling are you hiring actors to play
wrestlers or are we the wrestlers yes
Christ [ __ ] actresses okay I want you
to meet the star of glow Debbie Egan are
you insane
why is she here she's the alpha and
you're the Omega something she might
kill you
this is the Basten Howard our producer
this is my first Hollywood party there
are drugs in the [ __ ] robot wrestling
is about pipe you're a sexy party girl
you're an arrow
you mean serious right yes we know
exactly you're a big black girl
the [ __ ] you say lady wrestling I get it
women can do anything men do blah blah
blah
[Music]
how about look I got chills yeah you
would
we're empowered where the heroes want
the show to happen this is the only
place I get to do what I want to do
people respect me here we got to shoot
this thing like five weeks this could
either feel dinky or it could feel epic
so let's give them one story telling
story telling
this is about justice this is about
holding on to what's ours
[Applause]
[Music]
you